we felt that it was the first time in
the world would get a chance to see the
real core of the athletes in terms of
them being concerned about humanitarian
issues my name is John Carlos
track-and-field used to be my game born
and raised in Harlem New York travelled
the world and still try to get people's
attention father was a very simple
protests we felt that a way to get
people's attention was through shock
treatment the demonstration itself
consisted of three individuals Tommie
Smith Peter Norman and John Carlos the
artifacts that was involved in the
demonstration was black club beads on
one's neck a black scarf on one's neck a
black shirt to cover up the USA Jersey
my uniform was open to illustrate that I
was concerned about the blue-collar
workers of this nation that's always
forgotten we wore shoeless socks out
there to demonstrate that people of
color was very poor in the greatest
nation of the world and didn't go to the
moon and land a rocket ship a half mile
from where they said it'll land but they
couldn't stop hunger rodents roaches are
what happened from the ghettos of
America we was demonstrating bigotry
prejudice bias mayhem and the only
vehicle that we had was to our endeavors
on the athletic field we thought it was
very necessary to go out there and make
a statement that would be universal for
these individuals to make statements now
these individuals are the fruit of our
labor
we know the consequence of being black
in this nation and we have a very
serious ill that these individuals are
stepping up to the plate now this is not
about my wealth
about my status as an athlete or
entertainer it's about my life in my
history that I want to have corrected my
advice to speaking out against the
atrocities and stand fast for what you
believe in study which you're fighting
for while you're fighting for it and
what you're looking for in the long run
the outcome the Hall of Justice
moves slower than a snail's pace but
that still should make you have a
vigorous drive towards correcting the
ills of society